Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
cách SEO miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số
17 các thủ thuật Excel 2 phần 4/4 đây là
kế hoạch cuối cùng trong bốn cái bài về
thủ thuật Excel nhá trước khi bắt đầu
bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ giải đáp
các câu hỏi của bài số 16 hôm trước các
bạn mở cái file câu hỏi lên đấy thì cái
câu hỏi của mình là gì mình sẽ yêu cầu
kiểm soát cái việc nhập số liệu ví dụ cá
yêu cầu về số 4 nhá phải là kiểu số và
yêu cầu về mã công ty thì nó sẽ thỏa mãn
là diện nó sẽ phải có 4 ký tự và một ký
tự đầu là Tết và 3 cái kết luận sau là
số đấy thì đầu tiên mình sẽ làm với phần
số 4 trước nhắc nó dễ hơn đúng ạ thì bạn
sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn
muốn kiểm soát lại Ví dụ mình Bôi đen dự
phòng này đi sau đó còn và kẻ đa ta các
bạn vào data validation ở cái mục có lâu
đấy các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình nhận diện
các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình hâu Lang bờ đấy
à
ở trong các phần đây ta nhá Bạn thích
vào đây các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình là diện
nó sẽ có một số Bình Thuận à Ví dụ mình
chọn là diện glitter gian hoặc Bà Rịa
hoặc là glister thoại của Tu Đúng đấy
cậu sẽ chọn ở đây đi đấy mày xem minimem
là mình sẽ bằng không Đấy tức là diện
tối thiểu cái số 4 phải lớn họ Bằng
không nó sẽ không là số âm và nó không
thể là kiểu tách được đấy thì các bạn sẽ
thích ok lại Bây giờ bạn có thể nhập số
41 nói nhắc ví dụ là một lại thì ok này
ví dụ các bạn Nhập -1 tại thì nó sẽ báo
lỗi ngay đấy hoặc là gì Các bạn sinh
nhập -12 âm bao nhiêu họ có 20 nó báo
lỗi ngay đấy hoặc các bạn sẽ nhập cái
Tech vào đây nó cũng báo lỗi Ví dụ mình
nhận là gái xem đấy còn thấy nó báo lỗi
và nó chỉ cho phép các bạn Nhập cái giá
chuyện số thôi lại Nhập số thì OK đúng ạ
Bây giờ mày xóa đi thì như vậy mình đã
xong cái phần số vốn rồi nhá tiếp theo
mình sẽ làm cái phần mã công ty thì cái
này hơi phức tạp một tí thì giả sử mình
sẽ nhập cái mã công
eg1 23 tháng thì nhé Đấy thì mình sẽ xét
gì ạ Ở đây bản chất là nó sẽ có ba cái
điều kiện thì điều kiện một đại diện
điều kiện một Nó là diện một cái thứ tự
nó phải là tách đúng Điều kiện thứ hai
là việc 3 thứ tự sau là số và các điều
kiện chứ ba là nó phải là mình sẽ lấy
cái độ dài của nó phải bán bún thôi tư
mà mình chỉ khống chế cho nó là bốn cái
thứ tự đúng không bắt buộc là 4 ký tự
điều kiện một này điều kiện hay này Đây
là điều kiện ban đầu tiên mình sẽ làm
cái điều kiện một chút nhá các ký tự ban
đầu nó phải là tách đúng không đấy thì
toàn sẽ bằng này để lấy được một chút sự
ban đầu qua sử dụng máy hàn mép nha
khoán Tấn Phát ra cách ở đây chính là
cái ô mà các bạn cần lấy này phải số ký
tự mà các bạn cần lấy là thiệt là một
cái tự họ xem đóng ngoặc lại cao enter
thì nó được cái tự do rồi đúng không Bây
giờ mình sẽ xem các ký tự này có phải là
cách đây không các bạn tiếp nước vào đây
mình sẽ sửa mình sẽ thêm cái hàng vali
trước cái hành ghép lại các bạn ấn top
này đấy các bạn xuống cuối các bạn xem
đóng ngoặc đơn lại các
ở đây thì nó sẽ báo là rẻ lót bao lưu
tại vì sao ạ Tại vì kẻ nét ở đây mình
lấy một ký tự thì nó là là chuỗi rồi nó
không phải là số thì nó sẽ báo loa vali
các bạn tiếp lúc vào đây mình sẽ thêm
một cái hàng là y sinh năm bờ vào đây
nữa các bạn đánh tác nhé các bạn có thể
enter thì ở đây nó hiện cái thông báo là
bạn thiếu một cái đóng các đơn cho ạ Các
bạn tưởng biết đi đấy thì nó sẽ báo về
khô bây giờ các bạn lại thích đúng tiếp
mình sẽ thêm một một cái Hàn trước cái
hàng năm vào này là cái thằng lót nhá
các bạn đang pháp rồi các bạn enter Các
bạn cứ bấm nhất đi Vậy thì như vậy đây
nó trả về kết quả là Chu rồi bây giờ ví
dụ bây g123 mà các bạn xâm nhập vào định
1234 Các bạn thấy nó sẽ Bảo Lạc khô
người sẽ lưu lại nhé Thì như vậy TG 123
đây thì nó đúng là gì ạ các ký tự đầu nó
sẽ là Chu là đúng rồi nhá bây giờ cái
hàng này có để cho mình nha mình sẽ dùng
tất cả bốn hàng thằng nhóc này hàm y
Đang bờ hàng vali và mép đấy Cái Điều
kiện thứ 2 là diện là
các ký tự bên phải này rất là ba cái chữ
sau nó là số đó cậu sẽ bằng cái hàng
like các bạn đang tát nhá các bạn xúc
xích và cái ô mà có cần tách này phải
mình cách ba cái tự nó còn nó hoặc đơn
lại đọc enter tại thì nó sẽ ra là 123
các bạn tiếp nước vào đây mình sẽ thêm
cái hàng vali trước Hà Android là các
bạn tát nhá lại các bạn m mình sẽ biết
đi lại còn tiếp bước vào đây mình lại
thêm một cách hàm là hàm isnumber nữa
phải gọi đánh tát nhá gặp enter mình
biết đi đấy thì như vậy cái điều khiển
thứ hai ở đây nó là Chu rồi Tức là ba
cái thứ tự này thì ba cái thứ tự sau là
số rồi Tiếp theo cái điều khiển bốn thì
rất đơn giản các bạn bằng này led led
của ông này các bạn đóng hoặc lại và
bằng 4 đấy thì như vậy Ở đây mình có tất
cả là ba điều kiện này bằng chu là đúng
này bây giờ ví dụ mình nhập 1234 đấy Bạn
thấy chứ Thì cái 1234 này cái điều kiện
đầu tiên nó vi phạm này nó không phải là
cách đấy còn hai cái điều kiện này là
thỏa mãn
Ừ thế như vậy là gì ạ mình phải dùng một
cái hàm nào để mình ba cái điều kiện này
nó phải trả về kết quả là chua cơ lại
bây giờ ví dụ mình là nhờ này a b c hạn
thế nó báo lỗi này lỗi ở cái điều kiện
thứ 2 thìa nên vẫn là 4 chữ tự vẫn là ký
tự đầu tiên là gì Là Tết nhưng ba cái
thứ sau cũng gọi là số đấy Bạn thấy ví
dụ mình nhập là gì ạ Ví dụ mình nhập là
g 12345 đấy thì là gì ạ thì cái điều
kiện 3 này nó lại không thỏa mãn Tại vì
gì ạ Cái mã này nó lớn 4 ký tự đấy thì
như vậy mình phải dùng một cái hàm để
mình thỏa mãn ba cái điều khiển này tức
là mình sử dụng cái làm quen nhé em à Ba
cái điều kiện này bằng chu thì mình mới
chọn cho diện cho phép nhập ở đây là
g123 đây đấy thì các bạn sẽ mình chân
thích cái dấu nháy đơn ở trên này để
mình diện mình sẽ làm cái hàm các bạn
bạn với hàm em cho mình các bạn mặc Đơn
giản bây giờ các bạn em tôi nhá cái dấu
nháy đơn ở đây là gì là các bạn Gõ cái
kiểu thích thì để các bạn Nhập cái dấu
bằng ấy thôi
ạ Bây giờ các bạn nên các điều kiện một
các bạn thích và cái điều kiện một này
các bạn lên cái Thanh pho mua 3 đoạn
copy công thức các bạn copy công thức
tôi nhá các bạn đừng quá tivi dấu bằng
mình sẽ nháy được phản copy đấy các bạn
biết Bây giờ các bạn tích vào Cái ô này
so với hàm em nhé cậu thích lúc vào đây
các bạn gái thì phải chọn tên đi đấy các
bạn phải bây giờ các bạn ạ Em Tơ Đi bây
giờ mình sẽ copy cái điều kiện thứ Hai
nhé để gọn thích vào cái ô Điều kiện thứ
hai ở đây này các bạn Bôi đen các bạn
nhấn phải copy Các bạn có biết kiếp nhá
chọn tích vào cái ôm này Bây giờ bọn
kính ốp này sau cái dấu phẩy thì bạn
nháy được phải cà phê vào đây đấy các
bạn hãy phải tiếp để mình nhập cái điều
kiện thứ ma mà các bạn enter đi các bạn
tích vào cái ô Điều kiện thứ 3 lại toàn
bộ đen để gọn nhé được phải copy bạn
thích độ và cái Owen này các bạn xuống
dưới này các anh ấy phải cam kết vào đây
đấy các bạn thấy đóng lại thì như vậy là
gì mình đã xong được 3 cái điều kiện này
ở trong hàm em rồi đúng không đ
ạ Bây giờ bạn tích vào đây các bạn sẽ
copy cho mình từ cái dấu bằng nhá đầy
cát đừng copy cái dấu nháy lên nhá cái
rồi nhanh đơn thực ra là gì ạ Để mình gõ
cái công thức này cho bạn hiểu thôi Bây
giờ bạn sẽ copy từ cái dấu bằng các bạn
nhớ thì phải copy Chúc các bạn muốn biết
kiếp đi bây giờ quan có thể xóa hết cái
này cũng được ạ Bây giờ thì mình sẽ mô
đen các cái vùng mà con để nhập các cái
điều kiện nhá nào lại không tin nó thỏa
mãn ở trên này đúng không các bạn Bôi
đen trước này sau đó còn vào thẻ data
các bạn bảo diện data-validation đấy thì
trong cái thẻ sẽ tin nhá mục Alo các bạn
sẽ chọn cho mình là cá tôm đấy mình sẽ
biết công thức vừa xong mình copy lại
gọn trái đất phải các bạn sẽ công thức
của xong ở đây để chọn sẽ bấm ok để bạn
thấy bây giờ ở đây các bạn Nhập nha ví
dụ bạn Nhập 1234 là các enter để nó sẽ
báo luôn ngay đấy ví dụ nhập định 123456
hạ thế nó cũng báo lỗi ngay để ví dụ các
bạn Nhập là gà
a12 ạ Nó cũng báo lỗi ngay đấy cảm thấy
rất là hai ạ nếu như bạn Nhập b345 Mình
hãy nhá tại thì lại Ok c213 Thế Đấy đấy
là ok nhé Bạn cũng rất là hai ạ Ok như
vậy là mình đã xong cái câu hỏi của bài
số 16 nha các bạn đóng lại mình sẽ vào
bài số 17 của ngày hôm nay các bạn chú ý
nhé mình sẽ để cái link tải file thực
hành trong phần mô tả thế giới video tốt
nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn vừa theo
dõi và thực hành của mình nhá Nếu bạn
nào cũng biết cách tải thì các bạn có
thể hiện các bạn có thể xem cái bài đầu
tiên thì trong ngoài đấy mình đã hướng
dẫn các bạn chi tiết cách để các bạn tải
về rồi ạ cái file tải về sẽ là một cái
file nén sẽ gồm wifi nhá Đấy là cái file
thực hành và một cái file câu hỏi trong
bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn cách để bảo vệ dữ liệu thì sẽ
gồm 3 cái mục đầu tiên là diện bảo vệ
file bảo vệ xít và bảo vệ cái nhóm Excel
đấy ạ
thì mình đã hướng dẫn các bạn toàn bộ
cái cách mà các bạn có thể bảo vệ file
mà bạn mong muốn đúng không ạ thì đầu
tiên là diện mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
bảo vệ cái file này thì mình sẽ được bảo
vệ bằng việc bằng cách mình sẽ đặt mật
khẩu chỉ có ai có mật khẩu mới mở được
cái chai này thôi đúng ạ thì để làm việc
này các bạn làm như sau nhá các bạn sẽ
vào cái kẹp file này các bạn sẽ vào cái
info các bạn sẽ chọn gì protect workbook
này đấy các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình à dễ
entry Switch password cả thích ở đây lại
thêm một cái cửa sổ để các bạn Nhập cái
password mà các bạn muốn bảo vệ nha ví
dụ mình nhập là diện 123 nhập mẫu Thôi
thì các bạn nha Các bạn lên nhà cái mật
khẩu nó khó một chút nhé các bạn đừng
nhập 123 thì phải đơn giản quá thì ở đây
mình làm ví dụ thì mình nhận được 123
thôi Các bạn bấm ok thì nó yêu cầu các
bạn xác nhận lại thôi các bạn đăng nhập
lại mật khẩu mà các bạn đặt đúng đấy này
Các bạn bấm ok đấy Vậy còn đóng lại nhá
lại các bạn sếp đi bây giờ bạn mở cái
file này lên nhá Đấy bạn thấy nó sẽ yêu
cầu có
á khẩu mới mở được file này Đấy như vậy
Mình nhắc bảo vệ được file rồi đó mình
sẽ cho cái file này cho ai đấy Nhưng mà
nếu như người ta không biết mật khẩu thì
người ta cũng không thể mở được là các
bạn sẽ nhập mật khẩu đúng của các bạn
bạn Nếu như các bạn nhân vật của sai nhé
Ok nó sẽ báo lỗi nhanh và cũng nó sẽ
đóng cái pha đến nó chỉ còn phải ứng
dụng excel không Bây giờ mình lại Mở cái
file lên đấy Nó lại yêu cầu mật khẩu
đúng không Mình sẽ nhập với cậu đúng Các
bạn bấm ok rồi Tiếp theo mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn là bảo vệ sheet Đấy giả sử
mình muốn bảo vệ cái ship tổng hợp này
nhá thì mình làm như thế nào thì cứ rất
đơn giản gọn sẽ vào cái thẻ review này
các bạn sẽ chọn gì protect sheet đấy thì
nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ với taxi lên
để các bạn sẽ nhập mật khẩu nhà Ví dụ
mình đặt mật khẩu điện 123 Thế nhá Đấy
đoạn bằng Ok để lại yêu cầu quan sát
nhập lại nhé 123 gọn bằng Ok thì như vậy
cái sít này đã được bảo vệ rồi các bạn
tiếp vào đây nó sẽ không cho bạn làm gì
đó đây vẫn kỳ vô nào nó cũng không cho
các bạn làm gì cả cái như vậy
Anh bảo vệ rồi đúng không ạ rất là hai ạ
Bây giờ mình muốn bỏ cái bảo vệ đấy thì
mình làm như thế nào thì các bạn lại
phải vào cái review cả các bạn chọn
inforus thôi và buộc các bạn phải nhập
đúng bán thuốc thì các bạn mới sửa được
đúng ạ 123 Không phải mình đặt 1 2 3 mà
lại Ok Bây giờ bạn có thể sửa được lại
còn có thể thay đổi được nhá tiếp theo
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là cách để bảo
vệ nhóm các xe đúng ạ thì giả sử cái
phần đơn vị đơn giá và cái thành tiền là
cái phần quan trọng mà mình muốn bảo vệ
đúng không ạ Đấy tức là cái đơn vị đơn
giá thành tiền mình sẽ biết lúc cấp từ
cái Theme đơn giản này Đấy cái sự đơn
giản nó sẽ có cái sản phẩm đơn vị và đơn
giá đây lấy ví dụ như số lượng đây mình
sẽ nhập bất kỳ đi 23453 lại cái đơn vị
và đơn giá thì mình sẽ đúc kết lại các
bạn bằng với lúc cấp này các bạn sẽ
thích vào cái ô sản phẩm ở đây Đúng là
có phải là các bạn xanh ấy xin đừng dán
lại cạn Model cải cột b và cột D đúng
không đơn vị sẽ là cuộc số 20 phẩy hai
phẩy không có bạn enter đấy các bạn
thích là Cái ô này có
số liên kết anh Phong Lưu Các bạn nhớ
phải các bạn copy họ sẽ tích và hiểu đơn
giản này gọn nhẹ cho phải gắn kết vào
đây Đấy thì mình sẽ sửa số hàng thứ 3 để
mình lười gõ công thức mà chạy thì như
vậy Mình có đơn vị và đơn giản rồi đó
các bạn Bôi đen toàn thích nó vào đây
lại hai cái này mình sẽ xóa đi bây giờ
cái thằng tiền các bằng bằng cái số
lượng này các bạn Nhân Thiện Nhân với cả
đơn giá đã các bạn ăn cơm rồi các bạn bộ
đèn này các bạn có thể bấm Thanh Sơn đi
nhá cách tổng thể bạn sẽ bấm ăn mặn thì
nó là phím tắt của hàng xong mà đấy thì
như vậy Giả sử cái phần diện ba cái phần
này là cái phần quan trọng mình muốn bảo
vệ đúng không Mình không cho ai chỉnh
sửa cả đấy thì mình làm như thế nào thì
đầu tiên nhá các bạn phải tích cả tất cả
cái vùng dữ liệu của các sếp này các bạn
nhé về phải các bạn chọn format Cell đấy
Sau đó các bạn vào cái phần footaction
đây này Đấy thì bạn Thúy Nga vì mặc định
toàn bộ cái ô nó đang thích chọn là cái
nắp này
ạ Bây giờ mình phải bỏ chọn đi như vậy
toàn bộ các cô này đã không còn ôn nào
và gấp nữa Các bạn bấm Ok thì bây giờ
chỉ những cái ô dữ liệu mà các bạn muốn
bảo vệ thì các bạn mới lắp thôi đúng
không ạ Bây giờ bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái ô mà
bạn muốn bảo vệ đúng không để các bạn
giữ cần chôn các bạn thích cả ô tính
cảnh này nữa đấy Bây giờ có bạn nháy
được phải này các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ Các
bạn sẽ chọn cái phòng Excel lại các bạn
vào cái thẻ tôi taxin Các bạn chọn lọc
bạn bằng Ok đi Dậy thì như vậy cái ôm
này đã lắp rồi nhá bây giờ rất đơn giản
các bạn chỉ cần vào cái review Các bạn
chọn cái vụ Taxi mà lại hoặc là các bạn
nhớ phải vào đây Các bạn chọn với taxi
cũng được đấy là hai cách nhé và các bạn
sẽ nhập mật khẩu Ví dụ mình nhập là diện
ví dụ nhập gái sao đi để các bạn bốn Ok
thì nó Yêu cầu xác nhận lại rồi đúng
không các bạn gái xem thì tùy các bạn
nha các bạn Nhập mật khẩu Nào các bạn
phải nhớ lại các bạn cũng ok đấy thì như
vậy Cái ô này các bạn thấy cọ xích đu
này nó sẽ không cho sửa đợi đến đây là
à mà nó sẽ không cho bạn sửa nhé Còn ví
dụ kiểu này bạn sẽ có thể sửa ba thành
bốn rồi đấy Bạn thấy chứ Thì như vậy đó
đảm bảo là gì cái phần đơn giá cái đơn
vị và thành tiền nó sẽ không bị các bạn
sửa và nó sẽ tự động cập nhật đấy lại
mình sẽ sợ ai thay đổi công thức của
mình mà lại có thể thay đổi cái số lượng
bất kỳ vậy thì việc các công thức ở đây
nó sẽ tự cập nhật thôi lại cho enter lại
còn riêng cái vùng mà lúc đấy mình bảo
vệ thì các bạn không sửa được nha bây
giờ chắc Tóm tắt lại các bước để các bạn
bảo vệ cái xe nhé thì đầu tiên các bạn
phải lựa chọn toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu sau
đó là bỏ chọn lọc xe lên sau đó thì các
bạn lại làm ngược lại là những cái ô nào
mà các bạn cần bảo vệ thì các bạn mới
lắp thôi Sau đó các bạn lại làm các bước
như là bảo vệ xếp bình thường đấy Ok bây
giờ mà để sửa cái này thì cứ rất là đơn
giản các bạn chỉ cần enboost axit là
thôi lại và các bạn Nhập cái password
của các bạn ấy thì bây giờ các bạn lại
có thể sửa rồi những cái cô này rất là
hay ok như vậy là mình đã
hình ảnh của ngày hôm nay nhá mình sẽ
xem cái câu hỏi về nhà OK câu hỏi của
bài tập về nhà là Thiện yêu cầu là khóa
toàn bộ các ô chứa công thức Ví dụ ở đây
là cái ô chứa Công thức này ô này là ông
công thức đợi thịt bất cứ cái ô nào mà
chứa công thức thì nó sẽ khóa lại có
những cái ô là ví dụ ô này không chứa
công thức thì nó sẽ không quá nhá Đấy nó
khác với cái phần bảo vệ dữ liệu ở cái
phần trước là gì ạ Cái phần trước là
mình sẽ lựa chọn cái ô bằng tay thì bây
giờ yêu cầu là diện nó sẽ khóa toàn bộ
các ô mà chứa công thức bài tập về nhà
cho các bạn nhé Ok như vậy là mình đã
kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm
ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng
ký Kênh để cập nhật video mới nhất của
gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người
cùng học Excel nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp
lại à
ừ ừ